Lee SEDOL is getting ready to rumble on
Wednesday live across the Internet this
professional South Korean go player will
take on artificial intelligence program
alphago and the ultimate human versus
machine smackdown I said I am confident
because I thought that it would be still
difficult for the computers artificial
intelligence to read the human sense
such as intuition however what I felt
from listening to the explanation about
the algorithm was that alphago may be
able to mimic the intuition of humans to
a certain degree go who is an incredibly
complex game for example in chess the
number of possible moves is about 20
from the average position and go it's
about 200 and the number of possible
configurations of the board is more than
the number of atoms in the universe Lee
isn't sure he'll win all five of his
games against deep mind but perhaps he's
being optimistic alphago has already
wiped the floor five nil against the
European champion last October the first
time a machine beat a professional go
player and it's at this point the
project becomes more than just a game a
number of high-profile thinkers from
Elon Musk to Stephen Hawking are already
warning of the risks to humanity from
creating artificial superintelligence
the creators of alphago considered the
technology itself neutral for what it's
used for is up to society and certainly
a deep mind and at Google we worry about
lots of these things and we we are kind
of thought leaders on the ethics front
of you know how these systems should be
used in a way that will benefit the many
and not the few and will benefit society
for the good
the winner of Wednesday's contest will
take home 1 million dollars although
it's unlikely alphago yet has any
subroutines capable of processing greed